hello my name is markiplier and get
ready to learn about the fourth of July
and all its historical historical myths
so when we last left off there was a
whole group of pilgrims that had just
gotten done murdering everything on the
island and then they discovered that it
wasn't an island it was a whole country
filled with promise and dreams and hopes
[Music]
to each other for ourselves so the
Americans then decided to reject their
British ancestry and forget everything
that ever happened to them before that
and then they dawn the moniker of being
American along with it came the powers
of greatness awesomeness eNOS
and then there was a war and everyone
died all of us each of us every one of
us there was George Franklin Billie and
Batman all together sitting up at top of
the world
they all had ivory towers and big ol
crowns their dicks were he and then they
signed the Declaration of Independence
on July 4th - not 19 a long time ago and
that's why we shoot fireworks up into
the sky every year because they mask us
preemptively striking the aliens in
space